[Music]
new technologies have allowed us to
really rethink education as a journey
rather than an event and Stanford leaf
is going to provide an opportunity for
executives to engage in deep and
meaningful social interaction while at
the same time consume education at the
pace that's appropriate for them
Stanford leaf will provide you with the
strategic business tools and techniques
to drive change and transformation
within your organization we designed
this program for people who want to
learn on the job with the support of the
Stanford faculty and a community of
colleagues the format is designed to be
flexible so you can really engage with
the concepts understand how they can be
applied and allow you to start
transforming your organization while
you're in the program you're gonna have
the opportunity to interact with
Stanford faculty Silicon Valley leaders
coaches together with your peers in the
program we have a rich set of elective
courses all led by the best faculty from
the Stanford GSB and the University
overall you'll have the opportunity to
watch self-paced video lectures exchange
ideas and collaborate in team-based
projects engage in class wide
discussions and receive ongoing peer and
faculty feedback the participants will
interact as teams sharing problems that
have come from their own business
experiences using that to help their
colleagues in the program through the
challenges that they're facing within
their organizations and each course the
program will have multiple opportunities
for live interaction with the faculty
Stanford GSB is located in the heart of
Silicon Valley one of the most dynamic
and innovative places the entire world
there's a unique mindset here the
faculty are highly engaged in thinking
through how to translate their material
into this online environment and we're
really going to be doing something
special with this program we are really
excited about the depth and the rigor
that we're gonna be able to put into
this program that's one of the reasons
why we've decided to give participants
to lead certificate at the conclusion of
this program which they can use to
document their experience and the
expertise that they're going to take
away this is not a MOOC or a massive
online course this is really a way of
immersing yourself in the Stanford
community and this is designed to be a
highly selective program open to high
potential individuals around the globe
who are ready to engage and collaborate
with a small community of others like
themselves as well as to stamp for
faculty in a highly engaging online
format it's flexible collaborative at
your own pace on your own turf and
designed to meet the business challenges
that you're facing in your organization
you